das ist meine erste kamera dipol ex 16
objektivwechsel hat einen unheimlichen
lärm gemacht aber regisseur clemens
klopfenstein ist ein film mittel an über
20 filme gemacht die heute alle
digitalisiert werden
dabei sucht er im archiv immer wieder
nach verloren gegangenen tönen
klopfenstein gehört zu den pionieren der
solothurner filmtage und wir möchten ein
publikum finden möchten viele machen die
auch gespielt werden es ist 1967 an der
dritten ausgabe der filmtage fordern die
jungen filmer einen neuen film weg vom
schwerfälligen heimatfilm ihrer
vorgänger luftiges sache gemacht aber
auch mit reflexionen kino
sein erster solothurner film umleitung
gedreht im kollektiv nahm verfolgungs
und actionfilme auf die schippe
von da an zeigte klopfenstein alle seine
filme in solothurn
einer seiner größten erfolge war an
nacht lang für land
nein
er spielt eine nacht lang in den
bewegten 80er jahren von bern alles aus
der sicht ist etwas frustrierten
radiomoderators max schauplatz seiner
premieren in solothurn war immer das
landhaus der große kinosaal des
festivals bis heute klopfenstein hat
hier um den erfolg all seiner filme
gezittert für das schweigen der männer
mit polo hofer und max hüttinger erhielt
hat an den ersten schweizer filmpreis
doch nicht immer passt in solothurn und
klopfenstein zusammen
es gab zeiten da forderte er die
abschaffung der film tragen das meer um
geld als um den inhalte filme ging
solothurner filmtage als artistische
nummern oder zum teil und baseball damit
sieger jahre szene bringen
also das ist heute genug sieht dass man
selber abschaffen
das praxisseminar ganze betrieb als
sponsor aber plötzlich setzt heute zum
fünfzigsten jubiläum ist davon nichts
mehr zu spielen
einer seiner filme er ruft der sibylla
ziert das cover der jubiläumsausgabe der
film handelt vom alkohol und wie man mit
dem geiste der flasche die welt
verändert
klopfenstein bleibt bis heute der magie
des kinos nacht